.
Nein, ist gut.
- Hattet ihr einen Holzofen?
Was ist ein Holzofen?
- Ein Ofen, der mit Holz heizt.
Nein. Nein.
Darf ich noch etwas zeigen?
Ein Ofentürchen.- Ja, bitte.
Ein Ofentürchen?
Es könnte ein Ofentürchen sein.
Das ist die Gefängnistür.
Was ist das?
Die Gefängnistür
des Menschenhandel-Schiffs.
Wovon?
- Des Menschenhandel-Schiffs.
Glaubst du?
- Ich habe sie gekauft.
Ich konnte das ganze Material eines
Menschenhandel-Schiffs ersteigern.
Ich wollte das Törchen,
aber sie haben mir
eine ganze Kiste mitgegeben.
Aus dem 18. Jh.
- Sklavenhandel.
Ja, Sklavenhandel.
Wozu hast du das gekauft?
Diese alten Schiffstruhen
sind wunderschön.
Mit schweren, grossen Tresoren.
Ich hatte das als Polster hier.
Ja, ich komme, ich komme.
Als Polster.
Das passt hierher.
- Das passt ideal.
Man musste das Ganze ...
- Als ...
Wie?
- Als Symbol wofür?
Nicht als Symbol. Ich wollte
diese Anlage als Schiff ...
Drinnen war es wie ein Schiff -
mit einem Netz ...
... Schiffscontainer, einfach
all das, und das gehörte auch dazu.
Ich hätte dich angebunden.
Der 57-jährige Zürcher Christian
Drescher hatte einen grossen Traum:
ein Eventlokal mit Wellnessbereich,
hier auf der Glarner Fronalp.
Doch dann kam das grosse Feuer
und sorgte für ein böses Erwachen.
Und genau davon handelt unser Film.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Der 9. November 2019, Samstagfrüh.
Der fast 90-jährige Berggasthof
Fronalpstock steht in Flammen.
Verletzt wird niemand.
Ein grosses Glück,
denn Besitzer Christian Drescher
wohnt seit rund einem Jahr im Haus.
In dieser Nacht
ist er aber in Zürich.
Auch der Helikopter
kommt beim Löschen zum Einsatz.
Dennoch gibt es einen Totalschaden.
Unten im Ort Mollis
wohnen die ehemaligen Besitzer
des Berggasthofs Fronalpstock,
das Ehepaar Fränzi und Bruno Reich.
30 Jahre hatten sie das Stockhus,
wie man es hier nennt, betrieben.
Fränzi war im Service,
Bruno in der Küche.
Ihre zwei Kinder sind im Stockhus
auf 1'300 m ü.M. gross geworden.
Schöne Jahre, sagen sie.
Aber der Kampf um die Kunden
wurde in letzter Zeit immer härter.
Schliesslich entschieden sie sich,
auch altersbeding, zu verkaufen -
für knapp 800'000 Fr.
an Christian Drescher.
Der Brand ihres ehemaligen Hauses:
ein Schock.
Wie haben Sie den Samstag erlebt?
Ja ...
Brutal.
Man weckte mich und sagte mir,
das Stockhus stehe in Vollbrand.
Sie hat mich geweckt ...
- Ich habe das Telefon ...
Ein Polizist oder Feuerwehrmann
wollte wissen, wo der Gastank war.
Da fragte ich: "Wer sind Sie?
Weshalb wollen Sie das wissen?"
Er hatte nur seinen Namen gesagt.
Und dann antwortete er: "Es brennt!"
Und ich fragte: "Wo brennt es?"
Und er:
"Im Stockhus oben brennt es."
Ich war ungläubig und er sagte,
das Haus stehe in Vollbrand
und sie müssten den Gastank finden.
Dann realisierte ich es.
Ich schaute aus dem Fenster.
Wir sehen nicht direkt
auf das Stockhus,
aber ich sah
eine riesige Rauchsäule.
Und da realisierte ich,
dass es wahr war.
Ich bin dann zu ihm hochgerannt
und habe gesagt:
"Das Stuckhus steht in Vollbrand!"
Er konnte dann dem Feuermann
erklären, wo der Gastank ist.
Und dann sind wir hin.
Dann siehst du einfach das,
was 30 Jahre lang dein Zuhause war,
in einem Feuerball.
Wahnsinn!
Der Samstag ist einfach vergangen.
Da haben wir
noch nicht gross überlegt.
Am Sonntagmittag
war es schon etwas anders.
Das Wetter war schön ...
Und da hat man
die Bescherung gesehen.- Ja.
Schmerzt es noch?
So kann es gehen.
Wenn man das so erzählt,
kommt es plötzlich.
Nein, wir können ja nichts tun.
Bei aller Betroffenheit:
Im Glarnerland wird auch gemunkelt,
es handle sich um Brandstiftung.
Die Rede ist von "warm sanieren".
"Das stinkt doch zum Himmel",
schreibt jemand.
Das haben wir auch mitgekriegt.
Einige haben auch indirekt gefragt.
Ich habe immer gesagt,
ich glaube das überhaupt nicht.
Einfach nicht!
Ich hatte ein solches Erlebnis:
Eine Nachbarin
war mit ihrem Sohn unterwegs,
vorgestern oder so.
Der Junge hat dann gefragt:
"Bruno,
hast du das Stockhus angezündet?"
Ich habe gefragt:
"Wer sagt das? Mama oder Papa?"
Er ist zusammengezuckt
und ist davongerannt.
Das waren natürlich Themen
zu Hause am Mittagstisch oder so.
Der Junge
ist nicht selber draufgekommen.
Er hat das irgendwo aufgeschnappt.
Ich werde in Zukunft bestimmt noch
einige Male darauf angesprochen,
aber ...
Zwei Tage nach dem Brand
fahre ich mit Christian Drescher
in Richtung Fronalpstock.
Erst langsam
werde ihm der Verlust bewusst.
Du lebst in den Taghinein.
Du funktionierst.
Das Schöne ist,
dass ich drei, vier Freunde habe,
die emotionslos und sachlich sind.
Sie holen mich
in die Realität zurück.
Das ganze Esoterische, Gefühls-
mässige, "ich habe dich lieb",
kann man nicht brauchen.
Ich zumindest nicht.
Es ist lieb und süss, aber ...
Das hilft mir nicht.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Gehen wir mal schauen.
Schau dir das mal an!
Ist doch schön, nicht?
Wunderbar!
Übrigens ist Drescher mit fast allen
gleich per Du ― auch mit mir.
Beim Brandort
ist die Polizei auf Spurensuche.
Etwas näher, gleich da vorne
beim Busch, war das Bad.
Dort war die Küche,
das war das Fenster.
Nächste Woche
wäre die Innenverkleidung gekommen.
In der Innenverkleidung
hätte man verkabelt
und dann hätten wir ...
Das ganze Licht ging nur dann an,
wenn ich es explizit
überall einsteckte.
Das muss man nach unten kippen.
Ah nein, obendrauf?
Nach einem Brand Beweise zu finden,
sei etwas vom Schwierigsten,
sagt man uns.
Und wenn der betroffene Hausherr
selber vor Ort ist,
wird die Polizeiarbeit
noch delikater.
Schau dir die schönen Steine an.
Die lässt du aber hier!
Sie sind zerbrochen.
Aber du kannst nicht draufschlagen.
- Nein, wir behalten es.
Im Moment gehört das der Polizei!
Steh aber nicht drauf!
Wie?
- Du musst nicht draufstehen.
Nein, ich habe das so
aus dem Brandschutt herausgenommen.
Also gut. Sie haben hier
die neuen Deckel befestigt,
gegen Gas.
Das ist es. Und das rundherum ...
Keine Ahnung! Das ist vom Kamin.
Das lag hier unten.
- Schön.
Was hat es
mit diesem Frotteetuch auf sich,
mit diesen Rosenquarz darunter?
Die habe ich geerbt.
Ja, aber ...
- Als Deko. Rein als Deko.
Das gelbe Tuch lag obendrauf.
- Ja, als Schutz.
Weil sie ja sehr zerbrechlich sind.
Also muss man sie schützen.
- Ja.
Mir passt es ohnehin nicht, dass ihr
einfach mit der Schaufel reingeht
und alles zerdrückt.
Es gibt immer noch Dinge,
an denen ich hänge,
auch wenn sie schwarz sind.
Wir geben uns Mühe, die Dinge
intakt zu bergen.- Ich sehe es.
Damit wir Sie fragen können,
was es ist.
Ja, ich sehe es.
Sehr emotional.
Wollen Sie mir noch länger
so frech kommen?-Nein, aber ...
Wir müssen die Schlinge zuziehen.
- Welche Schlinge?
Mit der Beweiserhebung.
- Ich?
Machen Sie Ihren Job.
Es ist ja alles okay.
Mache ich auf jeden Fall.
Aber Sie sollen wissen,
dass das ein Lebenswerk ist.
Auf jeden Fall. Das war auch
so kaputt unter dem Tüchlein.
Bravo.
Sonst noch eine Frage?
Im Moment nicht.
Wahrscheinlich der Staatsanwalt.
Kein Problem.
Sie können mir ruhig vertrauen.
Gegen den Verdacht der Brandstiftung
wehrt sich Drescher vehement.
Das ergebe überhaupt keinen Sinn -
so kurz vor Ende der Bauarbeiten.
Schau dir das an! Wenn du siehst,
wie die Handwerker arbeiten:
Weshalb sollte ich das anzünden?
Jene, die eine grosse Klappe haben,
sind genau die ...
Ich kann es mir schon vorstellen:
die Taugenichtse in den Beizen.
Die müsstest du an den Ohren
hierher ziehen und fragen, warum.
Das Seebad Utoquai in Zürich.
Hier betreibt Drescher seit 1997
eine Sauna mit medizinischer Massage.
Du machst hier Wellness
und springst danach in den See.
Und oben gibt es Wellness
und du bist am Berg.
Ist doch schön?
Findest du nicht?
Doch.
Eine schöne Idee.
Nach dem Brand des Stockhus
hat er hier fürs Erste eine Bleibe.
Verdienst du gut damit?
Verdienen?
Was ist verdienen?
In der Zeitung hiess es,
du habest gar nichts mehr.
Aber das ist
etwas kokettiert oder ...
Dieses "gar nichts mehr"
war die Antwort auf ein Inserat,
in dem ich gefragt wurde,
was ich alles dort hatte.
Also ein Interview.
- Ja.
Und ich habe gesagt:
Die ganz wichtigen Sachen
hatte ich oben.
Alle meine Kleider waren oben.
Und Dinge aus der Vergangenheit.
Das, was mir wichtig ist,
hatte ich oben.
Hast du noch Fragen?
Aha!
Bist du Masseur?
Nein.
- Das machst nicht du?
Ich bin Sporttherapeut
und nicht Masseur.- Ah.
Ich habe ganz gute Angestellte.
Hast du letzte Nacht hier geschlafen?
- Ja.
Aber wo denn?
Hinten habe ich noch
einen zweiten Raum.
Und ...
Also nicht auf dem Massagetisch.
- Nein, das mache ich nicht.
Der ist zu hart. Ich bin zu alt.
Aber es hat ein Zimmer.
- Ja.
Ein Schlafzimmer.
Fast, ja.
Und zum Kochen? Eine Kochgelegenheit?
- Hier draussen. Hier.
Hier hinten sind die Toiletten,
und das hast du gesehen.
Und hier hinten haben wir einen
traumhaften kleinen Technikerraum.
Mit einer kleinen Küche.
- Ah, ja.
Und einen Grill.
Das reicht. Es braucht nicht mehr.
Also ich brauche nicht mehr.
Tagsüber
geht es erneut in Richtung Glarus,
wo er vor 15 Jahren
ein zusätzliches Metier entdeckte:
Berufsfischer.
Wie bist du nach Glarus gekommen?
Über ein Inserat?
Über das Golfen.
Beim Golfen ...
Beim Golfen erfuhr ich,
dass der Berufsfischer von Weesen
pensioniert wird.
Und ich habe mir gedacht:
Statt eine Familie zu gründen,
kann ich ja fischen.
Ah!
Ich habe mich beworben
und habe dann ein Patent bekommen -
als Einziger in Glarus.
Und dann bist du zumindest
als Zürcher am Walensee.
Du musst dir aber nichts einbilden,
Christof.
Du bist und bleibst ein Unterländer.
Du bist ein Zürcher, du bist ein ...
Du wirst geduldet in Glarus,
aber nicht mehr.
Ich bin wieder auf der Fronalp,
fünf Tage nach dem Brand.
Es ist viel los heute.
Versicherungsexperten, Kantons-
vertreter und Anwälte sind auf Platz.
Ein wichtiger Tag.
Wer wird wie viel bezahlen müssen -
wenn überhaupt?
Kamera und Mikrofon sind
bei der Begehung nicht erwünscht.
Auch die ehemaligen Besitzer
Fränzi und Bruno Reich sind vor Ort,
um Christian zu unterstützen,
sagen sie.
Er sei halt manchmal
etwas gar emotional.
* Gemächliche Mandolinenklänge *
Mit Fränzi fahre ich anschliessend
wieder ins Tal.
Jeder hat fotografiert
und jener der Gebäudeversicherung
hat gesagt, was Sache ist.
Was alles kaputt ist,
was wo war
und wo der Brand ausgebrochen ist.
Und wie sich der Brand
entwickelt hat.
Dass das Dach eingestürzt ist.
Es war ein nigelnagelneues Dach.
Nächste Woche
wäre es fertig geworden.
Ende nächster Woche
wäre das Richtfest gewesen.
Es war schon geplant.
- Das will er ja trotzdem machen.
Ja, dann gibt es halt sonst was.
Knapp vier Wochen nach dem
grossen Feuer, Anfang Dezember 2019.
Die Glarner Polizei
hat sich gemeldet.
Der Brandplatz Stockhus
sei freigegeben.
Fränzi, Bruno und Christian
wollen schauen,
was hier noch zu retten ist.
Welches Stockwerk wäre das?
Das wäre das untere Stockwerk
des Massenlagers gewesen.
Hier war all mein Privates drin.
All mein Privates war hier drin.
Auch bezüglich
der möglichen Brandursache
ist man offensichtlich
weitergekommen.
Hallo, Patrick.
(Mann am Telefon)
Ich rufe den Elektriker noch an.
Letzte Woche musste er zur Polizei.
Das weisst du ja.- Ja.
Er wurde befragt.
- Ja.
Sonst habe ich nichts gehört.
- Wir sind alle entlastet.
Ja, ja.
- Die Brandursache ist draussen.
Wie?
Wie sagt man?
- (Bruno) Unbekannt.
Unbekannt technische ...
"Unbekannter technischer Defekt"
hast du gesagt.
Ganz genau. Das ist es.
Wir sind jetzt oben beim Haus.
Die Baustelle
wurde gestern freigegeben.
Die Polizei
hat die Absperrung entfernt.
Die Information betreffend der
"unbekannten technischen Ursache"
habe er von der Polizei erhalten.
Allerdings:
Bei der Staatsanwaltschaft Glarus
ist die Strafuntersuchung
bis heute pendent.
Schau mal, siehst du,
wie die Decke durchhängt?
Oh, herrje.
Hier.
- Ja.
Die Fronttür ist ...
- Ja nu.
Wir beginnen ganz unten,
ich sage es euch.
Der Feuerwehrschlauch ...
Oh, jetzt! Hier sind sie!
Was?
- Meine Golfschläger.
Nein!
Das Eisen 9.
* Christof Franzen lacht. *
Hört auf, dumm zu lachen.
Wer nicht Golf spielt,
hat keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet.
Das Eisen 9.
Nein!
Das 60er Lob Wedge.
Hey!
Pass auf, dass du mit dem Kabel
keinen Kurzschluss erzeugst.
Der ganze Satz kommt zum Vorschein!
Nein! Nein, das glaubst du nicht!
In diesen Trümmern
liegt aber noch weit Wertvolleres.
* Kuhglocken *
Mitte Mai, ein halbes Jahr
liegt der Brand zurück.
Den Hausrat haben die Versicherungen
Christian Drescher
bereits entschädigt.
Und auch der Gebäudeversicherer
anerkennt,
dass ihm Geld für den Neubau zustehe.
Rund 1,4 Mio. Fr.
Vielleicht noch mehr ―
die Verhandlungen laufen.
Derweil freut sich Drescher
über alles,
was er in Asche und Ruinen
noch findet.
Schau dir das mal an.
Den konnten wir retten.
Ein Traum.
Den habe ich zu meinem 50. bekommen.
Was ist das?
- Ein geiler Anhänger.
Ich laufe halt so rum.
- Ist das Schmuck? Ist das wertvoll?
Das?
Weisst du, wie wertvoll das ist?
Symbolisch?
- Nicht nur symbolisch.
Da reichen 3'000 Fr. nicht.
Da, schau dir das mal an.
Hier hat es überall Löwenköpfe.
Der Stein ist drin geblieben.
Mit dem Abbruch der Ruinen
will er Mitte Juni beginnen.
Wann steht das Neue?
Nächstes Jahr im Herbst.
Also 2021.
- Da ist es noch geschlossen.
Dann ist es von aussen fertig.
Im Herbst und Winter 2021
machen wir die Inneneinrichtung,
und im Frühling 2022
ist die Eröffnung.
Erste Pläne für den Wiederaufbau
gibt es bereits.
Das ist ein Stockwerk höher.
Er dürfe diese derzeit aber
nicht im Detail zeigen,
die Bewilligung stehe noch aus.
Es soll aber eine tolle Sache werden.
Kurzfristig hat er so oder so
andere Prioritäten:
die Wertsachen unter den Trümmern.
Wo sind die verdammten Diamanten?
Verdammt!
- Das frage ich mich auch.
Die Diamanten fehlen.
Im Wert von 60'000 Fr.
Die gibt es noch zu finden?
- Ja, Kinder, die gibt es zu finden.
Weshalb hast du Diamanten
im Wert von 60'000 Fr.?
Ich habe keine Kinder
und keine Familie.
Ein traumhaft schönes Stück.
Mir gefällt dieser Stein.
Alles, was man findet, erzählt
gleich wieder eine Geschichte.
Die bekommst du nie wieder.
Schau dir das an!
* Gemächliche Musik *
Wenn es nicht so traurig wäre,
würde es noch Spass machen.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Tanja Morana - 2020